Before we hop into the engine,
we want to go over some animation and skeletal mesh editors.
What are all these icons that you're going to see?
Well, as described, the skeleton,
mesh, animations, animation blueprints,
and physics are all subeditors that we'll be able to
access and will show us various things that we need to see.
Starting with the mesh editor,
this is one of the editors that will allow you to see your materials,
level of details, and morph targets.
You'll also see the skeleton editor,
which is the other subeditor,
that will be able to add things like our workshop today,
adding a socket, adding virtual bones,
changing the preview mesh,
as well as previewing some animations.
You can create different asset types like
a static mesh from the pose,
and you can even manage animation notifies.
Now, here are several of
the different types of animation editors.
This is just an overview.
We will be looking at this a little bit more in the engine.
But as you can see, each one has its own special place.
One does for blend spaces,
montages, and animation sequences.
Another one is the animation editor.
Then finally, you can see the way to
bake some of these animations to a control rig.
Now, here in the editor,
if you remember the animation folder
where we saw the animation sequences,
we're going to access that again.
I'm going to open up the A bot
walk animation sequence by double-clicking on it,
and you're going to see here the animation sequence editor.
These are all animations that have been pre-recorded and
baked out from a sequencer type animation.
We wouldn't typically animate everything
from this animation sequence editor.
Rather, we would use this to edit
an animation sequence as the name implies.
There are a few things here in this timeline
that you may not recognize,
and so I want to introduce those to you.
You'll see this notifies curves
and some additive layer tracks.
Well, the additive layer track,
you could say, for example,
you could come here and select the arm, for example,
and you could set a key so that,
let's just say we want to key that right there
as the opening position,
and then just scrub through here to the animation,
and maybe rotate his arm more,
and hit the S as in Sam key again,
and you'll notice you'll see this curve created.
Let's just say we want to go all the way back down
here to the end, and we want to bring it back down.
You just kind of pull it right here,
and just kind of reanimate where you wish to place this,
and just hit S again.
Now, if you go back to the beginning,
and you press play,
you'll see his arm kind of moves and snaps out,
snaps because it's returning back to zero,
so in the looping, it would do that
if we were to use this animation later.
Now, you can record it,
and record a new animation, or new animation sequence,
just merely by pressing this record key,
and it'll ask you where you wish to save it,
so you can just hit okay,
and when you're happy with it, you can just hit stop.
As soon as you do that,
you'll notice you have a new animation.
I'm gonna take it back to the beginning,
and you'll see here, it does say,
new animation has been successfully recorded,
so now you could use this,
and just name it to my new animation,
and be done with it.
Now, here in the editor,
if you remember the animation folder
where we saw the animation sequences,
we're gonna access that again.
Now, I'm gonna open up the ABOT walk animation sequence
by double-clicking on it,
and you're gonna see here the animation sequence editor.
These are all animations that have been pre-recorded,
and baked out from a sequencer type animation,
so we wouldn't typically animate everything
from this animation sequence editor,
rather, we would use this to edit an animation sequence,
as the name implies,
but there are a few things here in this timeline
that you may not recognize,
and so I wanna introduce those to you.
So you'll see this notifies curves
and some additive layer tracks.
Well, the additive layer track,
you could say, for example,
you could come here and select the arm, for example,
and you could set a key,
so that, let's just say we wanna key that right there,
as the opening position,
and then just kinda scrub through here to the animation,
and maybe rotate his arm more,
and hit the S as in Sam key again,
and you'll notice, you'll see this curve created.
Let's just say we wanna go all the way back down here
to the end, and we wanna bring it back down.
Well, you just kinda pull it right here,
and just kinda reanimate where you wish to place this,
and just hit S again.
Now, if you go back to the beginning, and you press play,
you'll see his arm kinda moves and snaps out,
snaps because it's returning back to zero,
so in the looping, it would do that
if we were to use this animation later.
Now, you can record it, and record a new animation,
or a new animation sequence,
just merely by pressing this record key,
and it'll ask you where you wish to save it,
so you would just hit okay,
and when you're happy with it, you can just hit stop.
As soon as you do that,
you'll notice you have a new animation.
I'm gonna take it back to the beginning,
and you'll see here, it does say,
new animation has been successfully recorded,
so now you could use this,
and just name it to my new animation, and be done with it.
Now that I've cleared the graph,
let's take a look at notifications.
Now, what are they?
They're a way of adding, let's say,
some effects to this animation,
so let's say, for example, we wanted to,
I don't know, have an explosion
when his right foot hits, or plants,
so we'll say it kinda goes like right about there,
and I'm gonna right click within this area,
the notification, and I'm gonna add a notification,
and I'm gonna do a play particle effect versus a Niagara.
Now, the reason's because you would have to set up
a Niagara particle effect first.
To keep things simple, we're gonna use
play particle effect, and you'll notice,
yeah, nothing happens.
Well, the reason for that is,
is we have to assign a particle,
so by clicking on this, and going to the details,
you'll see we have all these wonderful
little explosions and fire,
so I'm gonna do a P explosion.
Now, we'll take this back,
and see if it does indeed trigger,
and boom, we get a little fire.
Now, let's say we wanted to do it on the left
as it comes down.
There's a couple ways you could do this.
You could actually hit play,
and simply copy and paste as this goes through,
or to be a little bit more precise,
we'll just take this, control C, and then control V,
and it'll pop it right where the scrubber is at,
so that's a nice little clue there,
is wherever the scrubber's at,
is where our effect will be, and boom.
Now, you may be wondering, can we go and do it in reverse?
There isn't a way right now to do that in there,
in this for simplicity's sake,
but you can through some different timing,
but for now, this is the simple way of doing it.
Now, let's say you're all done,
and you like this, say, hey, I really like this.
I wanna record it, so what you could do, again,
is you could go back here,
and do the same thing we did previously,
and then just hit play, and do record,
and name it firewalk, or something along those lines,
but this is just one of the many ways
that you can edit the animation sequencers
that are already made, or created,
by adding more additive layer tracks,
through changing some positioning,
or even adding some explosions.
So now that we've completed this animation sequence,
by adding an explosion, and maybe some additive layers,
like moving a bone here and there, to make the arm move,
we could also take this even further, and edit it,
even though we've recorded it.
So we can come up here, to edit in sequencer,
simply click that button,
and you'll see edit with FK control rig,
or bake to control rig, if there is an existing one there,
but we could just simply click edit with FK control rig,
and it'll bring it up within sequencer,
thereby we can adjust each one of the keys,
and further animate our sequence,
and bake it out, to be used later.
But before we jump into sequencer,
let's go ahead and work on our next project,
which is adding a socket.